[Music]
we have received concerns from eight
news now viewers an eight new viewer in
particular about this water leak in
Spring Valley residents right near Twain
and rainbow say they have seen water
flowing there for about two weeks
reporter Brian will spoke with the water
district tells us what goes into
repairing water leaks like this
it sounds like this that have a lot of
you asking why is the water flowing for
residents like Anthony Ford it's
something that gets on his nerves it is
a little bit annoying with with driving
my car through the water and kind of
skidding I've skidded once or twice just
getting through and I'm not even going
that fast but it has been very annoying
the past couple days you can actually
see the water coming up from the ground
and flowing through this parking lot
into the street
this is coming out and you know I would
hate to be walking down the street and
wearing some nice shoes or slipping or
having someone fall or something like
that and like causing any injuries that
would be horrible the water district
tells me when it comes to leaks like
this there are a lot of factors involved
it could be the responsibility of the
property owner or it could be the water
district that needs to fix it in this
case it's the property owners of
responsibility to fix the leak Ford
understands being patient and just wants
what's best let's get this picked up
let's get this fixed and keep our
streets clean the owners are aware of
the leak and have scheduled repairs for
Wednesday reporting in Spring Valley
Ryan will 8 News Now
if you notice water leaks like this
you're encouraged to report it to the
Las Vegas Valley Water District they do
want to stress patients as they work to
investigate each reported leak in the
area you can find all the different ways
to report leaks at 8newsnow.com